hi I'm welcome to episode number 46 of
the weekly Google clapper from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hi mark
how excited are you today I'm pretty I'm
pretty excited I am I'm pretty excited
yeah today we have the incredible honor
to have John Wilkes as our interviewee
and and yeah mark is very very excited
about this I'm pretty I'm pretty excited
I am I'm pretty excited I'm also very
excited to be honest so we're gonna be
talking with him about the history of
Borg and how basically Borg gave birth
to kubernetes what is the relationship
in between and and all the random things
he's pretty amazing yeah he is yeah I'm
pretty excited he's very excited and
after that we will go with our question
of the week which is actually quite
simple but not many people know about it
so I thought it was worth talking about
which is okay I love application before
credentials if you have not heard about
it we'll discuss a little bit what it is
but how do you use it locally there's an
incredibly easy way to do it it's very
cool yeah so so yeah that will be at the
end of the episode but now we're gonna
go first with the cool things of the
week yeah so we have some great cool
things of the week this time around we
had a pretty busy week this week with a
few things coming out just want to
highlight I think a couple of my
favorites first one being is we have
some new regions coming in 2017 which i
think is pretty exciting yeah some of
them I feel actually this this really
feels like a good place of a good list
of places I should visit so we have
London that I know already but Finland
and Frankfurt know I've been there so
Paolo I think in Australia that I think
is gonna be great
might have to go down to Australia
sometime around that opening that sounds
like a great event and also a Mumbai and
Singapore and Northern Virginia
yeah yeah so a bunch of new regions to
be announced next year and this was
actually announced during horizon
horizon so we'll have a link to to all
the announcement that happen in horizon
because there were a lot of them there
were a lot of yeah absolutely and and
there was also one thing that you're
involved with well I was loosely
involved I think that's maybe a little
stretch but we finally got a blog post
out about how Pokemon go runs on Google
cloud platform which is really really
cool so we talked a little bit in that
blog post about how they use datastore
for state management and how they have
one of the biggest gke clusters ever
done yes actually yes yeah the biggest
UK cluster ever possibly the biggest
kubernetes nobody knows I don't know
yeah it's that position all around but
yeah and and there's some graphs in
there and they talk about the new
customer reliability engineering team
and how everybody's do which is also
really cool hopefully we can get them on
the podcast I could loved it I would
love to do that too
but yeah definitely worth the read
especially if we play pokemon go yeah my
favourite thing about it is that little
graph that shows so yeah we were we're
expecting to have these amount of
traffic yeah we bought five times more
but after 15 minutes that was already
gone and we reach 50 percent 50 times
more than we expected like yeah ouch
yeah 50 times more than what they
thought they were gonna have and ten
times more than their worst case
scenario yeah so it was an enormous
amount of traffic a huge huge global
sensation yeah really really awesome
blog post so we'll have a link on the
show notes absolutely so why don't we go
do my favorite thing for this episode
and go have a chat with John so excited
yeah let's do that
today I am I am greatly delighted to be
joined by John Wilkes here together with
us on the podcast how are you doing
today John I'm good and I'm delightfully
grateful wonderful thank you so much for
joining us um for those people who don't
know who are whoever those people may be
I've been following your stuff for ages
and been a huge fan of yours for a very
long time mark is incredibly excited
I am pleased can you tell us a little
bit about yourself what do you do here
at Google I'm just this guy I work in
the Balch team which is part of our
technical infrastructure folk we write
software that runs a fleet of machines
that runs across pretty much every other
stuff that runs inside Google runs on
top of us so from the outside world
Google compute engine on pretty much all
the cloud products run on top and fork
Borg runs on top of a set of machines
Borg allocates those machines on demand
when people come along and say you know
I need 4,000 places to run this could
you find those 4,000 places we'll pick
them we will cope with the fact that
three of them will break we'll put them
somewhere else we'll work out how else
we can patch things into these clusters
of machines to make them use as
efficiently as possible so one question
that I'm I've been working at Google for
quite a while but I'm actually not sure
about the answer for how long we've had
board did we create it from the
beginning or we started it around about
2003 2004 long before I joined the
company so it began as a sort of small
scale activity with about three or four
people in collaboration with a new
version of our search engine so they
grew up together they each each built
home little features of the other and
they preferred that was used as a
initial deployment partner and from then
people realized it was just really
helpful for doing a bunch of stuff so
they could focus on what it was they
were trying to do in the search tools
and the underlying system would cope
with a bunch of stuff that they didn't
want to have to deal with and that was
useful not only for the search team but
for other folks as well so it started
getting widespread adoption and credit
where credit's to your name is on the
Borg paper right so I wrote the paper
with a bunch of other collaborators we
did a bunch of work and experimentation
about the system that many many other
people have built so I'm one of a huge
team of folk who've done the actual work
I'm just the guy who ends up being the
poor person talking out in the front but
they the people who did the construct of
the system they run it they keep on
developing it right now that's cool so I
guess it means right if you're someone
who's used Maps or search or Gmail
anything even above GCP in Google cloud
platform you've used board exactly
you would luck you haven't known it very
nice so for for the people that have
never heard the bad Borg
how good you described it what is what
does he do
it basically means you don't have to
worry about which machines you're
running on so you write let's say a
gmail developer right so you're
interested in the next version of some
the Gmail service that you so you build
a version of that you try it out
typically you actually you can test it
in our world either on your local
machine or in some Clara test systems
and then you just say great let's run
that on Bourg and that's it and you say
can I have 400 copies and it says sure
and that's all you have to think about
really provide you run come through a
few other hoops we'll get to in a minute
but you don't have to worry about where
those machines come from you don't have
to worry about what other things are
running on the same machine you don't
have to worry about if your task falls
over and you need to be restarted with
all of that stuff just cait's taken care
for you it ties in with things like the
security system it ties in with the
storage system so it gives you access to
it a date or elsewhere it ties in with
our internal networking communication
system so you can communicate it inside
the company and also through the outside
world in a secure fashion in a way that
everything is encrypted pretty much in
flight and it just relieves a bunch of
pressure and tension from the developers
so they can focus on adding the business
value that they're interested in so
you're trying to tell me that people at
Google aren't just like SSH into
machines and just copying binaries are
pretty much the one of things that make
sure that the only time you can SSH into
machine you have to go through a binary
which we've provided that make sure that
you have a reason to be on that machine
that there is some part of something
that you have authority to access that
is running on that machine otherwise the
answer is nope no yeah no that's very
cool having looked at and I'll reference
this probably a lot there was a
particular presentation you gave at
scale where you wrote like a declarative
file and you were showing how to how to
do hello world at scale with like
something like 10,000 copies or
something ridiculous what sort of stuff
would you end up putting inside that so
I'm guessing you had like a name and
then like do you do it's like a binary
you want to run something like that
pretty much so imagine you've compiled
hello will to run on your local desktop
so you bring it up to make sure it works
and it note displays hello world and
exciting fashion you know in a local
screen and then you wrap it with there's
a description about what you would like
to be true when it is running on Borg
and I use those terms carefully so you
say first of all
give it a name of some kind so we call
it a there's a collection of tasks
running the same thing a job so a job
has a name which is a text string and
whose name and things like that you say
where you want to run it and typically
you say a cell which for us is meat in
size cell is about ten thousand machines
we have them scattered pretty much all
the way across the globe if you go to
your favorite search engine you'll be
able to find a map of where Google
datacenters live each of those runs
typically several cells and you get to
pick one for various reasons to do with
the allocation policy to the next level
up you choose you say I want to be there
you say here's the program I've written
HelloWorld in this case you provided a
path to access that you if you want to
you can say things like how many CPU
calls it might need or how many
resources it should consume in terms of
RAM disk space things like that or you
could say yeah choose for me let the
system do that because we have a
technique for doing that and then you
say how many copies you want you can
stop with one and the maximum you're
allowed in any one place is 10,000 so I
did a quick demo running 10,000 copies
of hello world cuz you know why not not
exactly and it took about two and a half
minutes to get from 0 to 10,000 copies
roughly nice you kind of slip something
in there where you said it would likely
to be ah so it's not just saying oh I
want 10,000 so I get 10,000 it's
something slightly different so we have
this notion of things failing all the
time right I mean I'm a record of saying
that the reason Google looks like it's
up from the outside is that we assume
the world is collapsing around areas on
the inside and write software to code
before that happening so use that one of
the techniques that we use for that is
what we call this little declarative
statements about truth and in
reconciliation so here we have a
statement which says you know I would
like 10,000 copies of hello world
running somewhere and you can send this
off the board master and the book master
compares that with what is actually the
state of the world ago that's funny
nobody's placed 10,000 copies of hello
world so let me fix that so a component
inside the book master call the
scheduler goes and starts looking for
places for those 10,000 copies a little
wildly and remembers this fact right so
the other thing I need to point out is
that what you want to write down your
intentions your declarations in a way
that is super resilient for master uses
a
paxos which is a distributed fault
holler
and library implementation so every copy
of the book master has a copy of this
state and there are five copies in any
one cell so if any one of them goes down
the others can pick up and carry on at
least another line can pick up and carry
on so first of all write down your
attention I want 10,000 copies then the
scheduler goes and picks off a few of
these at a time and black finds places
for them to run spare spare machines in
the cell or more likely a fraction of a
surveyor machine somewhere in the cell
and it writes down his decision machine
number 17 has a copied machine number
423 has a copy then that also gets
written out in a persistent declarative
fashion so if the scheduler falls over
you can pick up and carry on where you
left off and then the finally what
happens is that the book Marsh itself
has a component which compares the state
of the world on the machines in that
cell to what it thinks should be true
that's funny that machine is supposed to
have a copy of this hello world but it
doesn't have one let me fix that and it
got the head and tells the UH nation
sitting on that machine to go grab
itself a copy of hello world and start
running it so that loop of comparing the
outside world against what you want to
be true turns out to be remarkably
resilient in case of failures you can
sort of fall over anywhere in the
process and then pick up from where you
left off and sort of just get back to
where you want to be very interesting so
that means that at the beginning we're
gonna have we're gonna say it was like
oh we're missing ten thousand copies but
then later on we're gonna be oh we we
have like nine thousand we're missing
only one thousand and at what point do
we can see the date' scanner stable and
how how long like you said two minutes
and a half for ten thousand so it took
from zero to two and a half minutes to
get up to almost ten thousand and it
turns out that I mean the the book
master is always trying to make ten
thousand copies running hmm but
typically it happens that there's a few
of them and when I was looking I saw
about sort of seven to ten of them we're
not running even in steady state
interesting is that just a problem
because you have 10,000 of them or is
there something actively saying no maybe
hello world isn't the most useful thing
in the world to be running 10,000 copies
of it is important to say hi or though
my hello world are you demo
though that turns out actually
helloworld was the least important thing
in a system and now that matters to what
I'm about to say things go wrong all the
time
occasionally machines break I mean when
you've got ten thousands of them in a
cell they will actually break it up
break it affair clip in absolute terms
but in relative terms these things are
amazing reliable they'll stay up for
quite a long time
however we will take the operating
system down roughly once a month in
order to do a software upgrade maybe
because we've become a better version
the kernel or maybe we rolling out some
security update or you know all sorts of
good reasons for doing this when you
take the operating system down you
basically have to reboot the Machine and
reboot the machine all the stuff that
was running although it's going to have
a bad time so that basically is the
primary driver if you're a production
task imagine something like Gmail or
Google Docs or Google cloud platform
products those things will see an outage
roughly once a month if they're running
all the time that's okay for them
because they're used to having other
coffee somewhere else so it's not a
problem you just write software to cope
with the fact it's going to go away but
it means that there is a sort of slow
gentle churn of things being removed now
that's sort of what we call production
stuff which is the things we really care
about we have other things like patch
jobs which are less important or least
maybe they're more tolerant of things
going wrong it's the way to think of it
and because they're more tolerant for
MapReduce job losses to workers that's
fine it's plenty more where that one
came from or maybe we'll bring this one
back and get another coffee and maybe
it'll be delayed a second or so yeah no
big deal if it's running for six hours
the that gives them more flexibility so
will actually allow them to get pushed
out of the way if we need space for
production tasks to run so if your
production tasks you know you have a
high priority if you have high priority
and there's a low priority thing in your
way you win the low priority thing get
bumped off a task dies and it will get
started somewhere else with this room
that's fine and you know there's this
priority order it goes from some 200
issues where we run production stuff
down to zero which is the lowest of the
low which is where hello world was
running so if any other task in the
system needed a resource that my hello
world was sitting on hello world got it
goodbye hello world goodbye
very cool so most of the things that
you've been talking about I have the
impression that were limited to a single
now is there one board Purcell is Borg
and also selves how does that work oh
this might be a great point to say this
book is the an internal codename it's
not an external trade name oh yes though
is gonna be happy about this right so
it's just just an internal codename we
try to avoid another Borg and the
association's as that go with that it's
all right bad new toys a name before my
fault we divide our talked about we have
a fleet I'm not gonna tell you how big
but it's big we divide it up into chunks
those chunks are designed to be big
enough to run some of the largest
applications we need to run but small
enough that if you lose an entire chunk
because I don't know software bug or
soft one of our site reliability
engineers miss types the name of one of
these things then it's acting not too
bad which is why 10,000 is an
interesting number it's big enough to be
able to get a lot of work done in one
place and it's small enough that you
know you can have two or three copies of
your application running in different
places so one of the reasons why these
club before clumps these cells are the
size they are is to allow sort of
failures and to bound to scope of the
mistake the other is so you could do
things like software updates write news
take them down and put them back up
again so the thing is designed to cope
with pretty much anything disappearing
at any moment for example the if the
book master has a software bug and
disappears all the stuff that's working
in the cell right now stays working
doesn't stop and the agents on each of
the machines that will try to contact
the ball blaster will keep trying and
eventually it will come back and they'll
just pick up where they left off so they
think in the meantime they will just
keep working on what it was they were
last asked to do yeah you
I mean we kind of keep going around it
and talking about it I kind of want to
highlight it as a really interesting
point that everything is built for
failure like it is an assumption of
failure yes everything will break at
some point and I think that's a really
interesting like software development
practice to start from like everything
is bad rather than in an ideal scenario
this server will be up forever
I think that's really really interesting
so a lot of the design discussions that
I get involved in or around you know
what happens when that fails while
you're doing this other thing have you
made a slightly flaky assumption that
it's just it's gonna be okay cuz it's
gonna keep working
I was in a room one time it was
listening to a talk of somebody
describing one of our internal systems
and he was sort of skating over one of
these areas and there was gonna have 50
or 60 people in the room and somebody
asked him a question about a particular
thing it turned out that they'd allowed
a race condition to happen and there was
a point where it could go wrong and I
think about 1/3 of the people in the
room put their hand up at that point
simultaneously that's really cool all
right so that's really interesting so
you've got this declarative syntax you
tell like your system what it is you
want that means you have to have a lot
of trust in the system that you're
running on how does that get like
verified or do you just trust it and
you're like it's fine but I mean you're
building for failure right so how does
that work there's a slogan which really
works here if you're not measuring it it
is out of control
so trust but verify right you need we do
put a lot of effort into designing
systems to be fairly tolerant including
the systems that run the systems that
are designed to be failure tolerant and
so on all the way up and down the stack
but you want to make sure that it is you
actually need to measure it so we put a
huge amount of resources into monitoring
the systems that we have including the
systems that are monitoring the systems
we have and they will report things like
this is what I was expecting to see this
is what I'm currently seeing and if they
differ in the wrong way around
then you fire off alerts you get people
involved the goal is to know people are
always at the top of the stack they
people can do things that no machine can
never do but you want to have the
Machine automate the process of doing
the sort of regular straightforward
stuff for example we were talking
earlier about some tasks being killed or
pushed off a machine this is normal you
don't have to write special code to
handle this as an unusual exception this
happens all the time so you write the
software to have that happen all the
time and then you move on and then you
check that in fact if you ask for a
hundred copies of it you've got close to
a hundred copies running yeah but there
is some monitoring system which is
keeping an eye on that and displaying it
and telling eventually a human maybe for
another intermediate system that you
know don't have you to have fewer than
you expected now to make that work the
people who write the software in which
you rely typically have to tell you how
much you can rely on it so we have
internal specifications of how often
things break for example we have a sort
of some rate limit or rather an
expectation how frequently
your tasks can be removed hmm so you
write your software assuming that that
rate is propoganda net and then we have
our site reliability engineers who run
these systems and they're spectacularly
good at making sure the system's both do
what they're supposed to do and do it
within spec and they get invoked fixes
and do whatever they need to do if it
turns out the system is not behaving as
it should be the only way they know that
is if they're monitoring it and keep an
eye on it but that means that gives you
a handle on to say so you don't know
where you know that there is no
unbounded limit at which things are
going to go bad we will tell you here is
enough plausible upper bound on how bad
things could be and write software
around according to that so that is
actually something very interesting that
is that word at bigger scale becomes
what we call an SLA a server a service
level agreement becomes the SLO part of
the SLA SLO yeah right so just
terminology for yeah right so reserve
level objective objective there you go
the way I think of it is something I
want to be true I'd love there to be
yeah more than about this many failures
per week and something that I thought
was pre amazing when I was reading the
SRA book it was about SL O's and how if
we are having our SLO is higher than
expected sometimes we will just make our
services fail just for fun sometimes you
find people mistakenly assuming
something is going to be up because it
always has been whenever they've looked
well if it turns out it might not be and
they've made an assumption that it is
that's a failure they've just written
for themselves so for example we have a
system internal be called chubbie which
we use for storing relatively small
quantities of information that is
incredibly available we have local
versions of it in every cell or pretty
much every cell we all have a global one
which is more convenient to access but
we do not promise it as always there so
just to make sure that if you choose to
use it you cannot rely on it and the
people who run that service will
deliberately take it down once a quarter
and then we find all those people who
fall over because they were assuming
global trouble
there and we gonna fix them because they
are not acceptable so that's one reason
for why you might choose to inject
failures to find faults and the second
reason is that maybe if you're making
your system to good you're spending too
much money on it you can maybe a column
eyes you could maybe use fewer resources
or maybe have a few less copies or be
willing to take the resources you're
putting into that system to make it
behave well and move it somewhere else
we would have more benefit to a business
or a customer yes it's kind of that
whole thing right it's better to do it
like in training or when people are
watching for a bad thing to happen than
to have to let go oh it's an emergency
let's do it right now absolutely yeah
but you also have to prepare for
emergencies and be ready to do it right
now which is why having people
incredibly good at this running your
systems is the right way to go so
regarding that that issue of making sure
that things don't rely on things that
could go down is it also true that
sometimes we will take down actual data
centers or things like that not just for
fun as we said but to make sure that not
like not crazy assumptions are taken so
we do this annual exercise we call dirt
where we first of all begin by assuming
that the company headquarters has laid
into the sea in California yeah and is
this connected from the rest of the
world so can we keep running Google
without Mountain View in the answer
pretty much is yes and then we add some
interesting mix to it so my favorite
from one year was that the operations
team in Dublin apparently went out
drinking one day wasn't gonna be back
for several days another version of this
is we simulated we didn't actually do
this oh thanks I guess let's pretend we
have lost all power to one of our really
big data centers and you discover what's
gonna happen right well what happened is
those people go good grief we've got a
bunch of stuff running we have diesel
generators they can do switch on they
start burning through diesel to keep
these things running they're assuming
producing an awful lot of power and you
call up the local diesel suppliers and
say gimme trucks full of diesel get them
lined up right now because we're gonna
need to move them as fast as we can to
keep the thing afloat and then somebody
says great how're you gonna pay for this
well the people are mad in Oh
oops so that's why you do these
exercises is you have a chance to find
out those things in a world where it
isn't actually disaster right yeah you
can cope with it ahead of time and go
let's fix that yeah another example
where something happened was we
discovered we needed to get every
building on the foam bridge to be able
to talk about it because we have systems
that are spread across the globe and we
have experts in different countries in
it panicking trying to get something
done and they couldn't set up the foam
bridge because that ride to ride on a
piece of software that was currently
down nice the fix for that is quite safe
forward you always have a phone bridge
ready to go and everybody has these
numbers that needs it and off you go so
those are the kind of things that you
don't think of until you go through the
process and then you go nope why didn't
I think of that well as you build up
experience in this and it might I think
the sre book is a wonderful example of
that it's basically a distillation of
several thousand people times a dozen
plus years of experiences of making or
discovering opportunities for not
screwing up and writing them to have
other people so we could spread the
wealth standing on the shoulder of
giants there we go yes so Alice let's
change tack a little bit I don't want to
go over time as much as I want to just
talk to you forever and ever we will
want to talk a little bit the open
source project kubernetes there's
there's definitely direct influences
from borg and what we do at Google as a
whole to communities I think
specifically around like lessons around
failure optimization trusting your
system you know some history about how
could we days came about I think
probably heard about it but like what's
that connection there so indeed yes it
was some people who are associated with
the Borg ecosystem who were involved in
its creation so came out as a
combination of the sort of Borg and the
cloud ecosystem that we were building
internally and you know somebody noticed
this wonderful use of containers we use
them internally we have used them for a
very long time bordick Borg is built
around allocating containers they're
just a way of encapsulating your program
so it can run pretty much anywhere I
talked before about running on the
desktop and then also being able to move
into into the bulk universe the same
thing is now possible in the external
world thanks to docker which is just a
really nice tasteful combination of a
bunch of technologies that were floating
around if somebody went and said good
grief if we put these things together
we've got essentially the same idea
the doctor came out in the outside world
and about the same time so how cloud
business was was getting going an
interesting way and we went ah wonderful
opportunity for us to share our
expertise and make this available to the
larger ecosystem so if you've got you
know one instance of a one application
running in one place then that docker
container is just fine right you can
launch in your copies of it you can send
it up you can test it once you get to
about ten or a hundred of these things
it gets tedious to do this by hand hold
on we've done that before there's a
pattern we've seen here let's see if we
can replicate that pattern in the
outside world using off-the-shelf
software in the open-source community
and make it available to other people so
that we can build an ecosystem and have
everybody contribute to this so it's not
just a Google project it's actually an
open-source community that's been
created around this stuff we have lots
of contributors and thousands of them in
the last count trying to help the
kubernetes become better kubernetes is
the ad outcome right it's one way of
looking at it is it's a sort of Borg
lite version - don't try and take the
the most important parts of the lessons
we've learned including things like the
failure tolerant so vog uses paxos for
its internal persistent store kubernetes
use EDD to get the same effect there's a
central place where you could have the
master in it you say I wish this to be
true and the same kind of protocols that
we talked about before are applied
there's an agent in every machine called
the Kubler much the same way there's a
Borg locked on every machine in the Borg
universe so all of those ideas are very
similar and then we added a few new ones
based on our experience with Paul and
we've been running this thing for a
decade or so now and we've learnt there
are a few things it does that we wished
it didn't
so let's not impose the hat on the head
saying hey let's see if we can throw
only new mistakes so that's really how
it came and it turned out in a lot of
the people who are now currently on the
the Google portion of the kubernetes
effort rx4 people they either moved 20
feet down the corridor and it's like
where they were you can switch projects
and I understood no blind the expertise
they built up over over the years and in
the book universe - the kubernetes space
so that is that is interesting you said
that we could see kubernetes as an kind
of an an an evolution of board with all
the things we've learned over the years
what is the biggest difference you get
you get your thing is worth mentioning
it's open source
okay that is a very good fine yeah
there's people of a every now and again
ask me so why didn't you open source
pork and I sort of look at them gently
and go you have no idea how much of the
internal Google ecosystem tentacles
reach their way inside our
implementation I just know we couldn't
do it even if you wanted to gentle hard
but if you star from scratch and if you
target being an open source project and
you aim for an apache license and you
use a different language to make sure
you don't accidentally have dependencies
on things so vollgas in c++ kubernetes
its is in go you end up with a thing
that is actually far more valuable to
the outside world and which is great to
me that's what it's all for
and as a result we have many people
contributing to it and it's gonna making
rapid progress so one of the difference
that I that I heard was also very
important other than open sourcing or
not was labels
I've heard that labels is a thing that
is not part of board is that true and
why do you think that labels were added
to kubernetes because we actually were
trying to add them for Borg and we might
we made progress on it we use them in
the outside world in our Google Cloud
product yeah II platform and they turned
out to be a much more flexible way of
grouping things together right so Borg
has a notion which we call the job which
job is just a set of pretty much
identical tasks but that's all it has it
doesn't have any way of grouping subsets
and together or overlapping subsets or
those kind of things and labels let you
do this right you put a label any label
you like on a set of tasks and then say
do some things like tell me the
performance of it or do an upgrade on or
take it down or bring up a new version
or et cetera on all the things for which
this set of labels applies so now they
have basically sort of Venn diagram set
like behavior on any mixer if you like
and you get to define it you don't just
have this one single factor that is a
very constrained way to do business so
that was one of the lessons right so
Borg provided a primitive it was helpful
but it didn't go far enough
it was the same simple new abstraction
of labels we get to take you can
reproduce the behavior we used to have
in Borg but you also get all this other
stuff as well so that's a win-win yep so
that actually makes I guess monitoring
easier because you can monitor first
really the tax that the tasks that you
care about which made me think about
okay so you
said that everything at Google runs
aboard or mostly everything was the ever
seen men and that to make sure that
board is working correctly
we have monitoring that's the monitoring
for board run on board good question
yes house so the monitoring systems are
jobs that Borg runs but remember I told
you if the board master goes down the
systems it was running stay up there's
no reason why they should stop and you
can also monitor one Borg cell from
another interesting so actually said one
of the interesting projects underway at
the moment is to say what would happen
if we turned off all of Google from
scratch Oh God
if is the standard way booting up a new
cell is to go grab a bunch of stuff from
another one because it's up there yeah
yes exactly so this is the kind of
thinking where somebody starts going
let's talk about failure modes we
haven't thought about before which goes
back to our foot one of our Olien yes
right imagine the worst case none of the
worst case the worst worst case Wow
then almost comes back to like we're you
need to read communities directly like
federated communities and being able to
do cross cloud it's like okay yeah we
have this cluster of ten fifty a hundred
thousand machines that's great what if
that data center goes down well what if
that cloud provider goes down or my own
print like I want to be in multiple
places at once like let's think about
that as a fair way since I am and also
it means that it also gives you freedom
of deployment right this separates the
decision about where you run from what
your application developers right if you
have a standard API like the kubernetes
one you get to write to this API and you
can run exactly the same thing locally
you can run it on premises in your own
datacenter if you want you can run it on
cloud provider one cloud provider two or
maybe a mix of all of these things yeah
and you can change your mind at any time
you're not bound to one other things so
that freedom of flexibility and
deployment is is a wonderful thing that
kubernetes gives you unfortunately we
are running at a time very I'm
dreadfully disappointed is there
anything that we haven't touched on or
you want to mention or talk about a plug
or anything like that that we haven't
had time to cover Google Cloud is a
wonderful way of being able to leverage
pretty much a bunch of stuff like the
things I've been describing so you don't
have to do all that work I mean the same
freedom that we give internal
is the part of the message behind things
like the cloud products right now so you
can rely on stuff I was Illinois giving
a talk last week about some of our data
flow and storage products and in the
middle of it I was able to do a live
demo of doing a search in a petabyte
table took about 12 seconds oh wow
that's the kind of thing you want to be
able to take advantage of to get your
job done you shouldn't have to be
worrying about blue link building the
infrastructure to do that so this is the
story behind Borg it's the story behind
kubernetes and it's the story behind the
entire group cloud product line right
focus on what you can bring to that
value to them and then build on
best-in-class implementations of stuff
underneath you can put and get from
other people
great I have one more question
can you share so you've been working on
board for quite a while can you share
what are you working on like what is the
next crazy thing you're gonna be working
about like if we if we interview you in
a couple of years what we what would
what would we talk about
that's a great question I'm gonna duck
okay so you know what you know what that
means a couple of years from now we'll
grab John again and we'll interview him
once more that sounds good this was fun
thank you very much thank you very much
so thanks so much again to John Wilkes
for such an interesting episode I I was
so sad that the time ran over I yeah I
wanted to I want to have him again good
we could talk to him for days days days
yeah a very very interesting
conversation I I don't know I I think
that I learned a lot I will have a bunch
of links to especially to the talk he
gave a dot scale getting that is a very
good to watch to to understand a little
bit more about we're talking about but
yeah he's amazing so again thanks so
much for coming so I think it's time to
go with the question of the week yeah I
think this is this is a really
interesting one so within the SDKs we
provide for Google cloud for accessing
services that we have like saying we
datastore or authentication or or
storage stuff like that we have a thing
in there called default application
default credentials and that makes it
really easy so if I've got say some card
maybe it's running on App Engine or GCE
I can default Li just go okay I know
you're running on GCE which is internal
to our project so you don't have to do
anything special to authenticate to log
into like a particular service and
that's great that's dandy that's awesome
what do I do if I'm testing locally but
I want to be able to connect to that
thing in the cloud that I would know me
so yeah so the important thing to know
is that the way these works is by
accessing some URL that is only
accessible from inside of your own
network right so so if you're running it
locally fortunately you don't have
access to that casino security yeah so
the only way of doing this before was to
download JSON file so go create a new
service account on the console and then
download that file put it in a good
place and then make sure that you have a
the correct global variable name for
environment variable pointing to that
JSON file now yeah my brain hurts now
you can do G Club beta of application
default login that's it and that just
grabs the thing it needs all the things
does the magic yeah it's automatic so
basically you have some if you have a
call to pick a get application before
credentials from your code it will just
work that's really cool it is pretty
amazing I've used it a couple times and
I was surprised because I really
expected that oh so what's next step ins
the next episode you're done
yay yeah so that's really cool it means
then you can be like sometimes maybe if
you want to use an emulator if that's
available you can do that or you can
connect to the service it's actually in
the out and you have really easy ways of
doing yeah as we mentioned in a previous
episode there's there's some emulators
like their store hasn't relator for it
which is really cool but some of the
services do not have those emulators and
sometimes you do not want to end it you
actually want to talk to the service so
real service and doing the the
authentication in those cases can be a
little bit hard right yeah so so yeah
that way you can run your your tests
directly on your laptop which is on a
completely different network without
having any other issues which is awesome
cool well why don't we tease a little
what we're gonna be talking about in the
next couple of episodes because we do
have those lined up yeah so
one of the topics gonna be cloud abuse
yeah so possibly if there is anything
bad happening on your account or doing
anything that possibly breaks Terms of
Service yeah basically what are the
things you should avoid doing and what
happens if someone is somehow hacking
you and doing those yeah you will get a
notice saying hey something was going on
what do you do so very interesting topic
and most of the things are related to
well you you go hacked right like
somehow someone got access to your
instances and they're doing something
that they should not be doing yeah so
the Epis are right after it's gonna be
about how do I secure my network
basically so networking on Google cloud
platform yeah there's some two really
good conversations which ya should
definitely listen in for yeah breaks out
about those they're they're pretty
pragmatic they're like okay so this
happen what do you think yeah right
worst-case scenario type stuff which is
great so I know you're out and about a
bit over the next week or so I think
when this episode comes out who be and
yeah is that right so when this episode
comes out I will be in New York and
actually I'll be probably on my way to
go to the Economist where we'll be
running and learn how to bailed high
scalable web apps with go workshop
hosted by women who go but if you want
to join these open to anyone so feel
free to check out the show notes and
join and if you cannot go it is totally
fine because on Monday I will be running
basically the same thing but I go remote
meetup that sounds like what's a fun I
have looked at that workshop it's a lot
of fun yeah because it's about to be a
source yeah soon soon what about you the
day after this episode comes out I will
be at siege in Atlanta I am particularly
excited about that because they said oh
we'll give you four minutes to rant
about whatever you like in regards to
the games industry nice and I like
complaining it's lots of fun
so fill up our advocate developer
advocate so the additional whiner
so I am I am actually complaining about
people not being able to talk about the
games
nice very interesting yeah so that'll be
lots and lots of fun
cool so yeah and if you if you are
anywhere where you can find us don't
forget that we do have stickers stickers
come get them I think that we have not
done these for ages so why don't we
remind everyone how to get in touch with
us sounds good so what's the website
GCB podcast.com or cloud the google.com
slash podcast if people want to email us
don't know hello DC podcast comm
excellent subreddit our slash just
podcast Google Google Plus plus GC
podcast twitter @ GC / podcast slack
there's a podcast sub comunist jano in
the Google cloud platform community yes
channel community yes yeah you got it I
got it you got it
was it miss anything I feel like you
forgot something but I don't know which
one so okay so anyway get in touch with
us send us your questions of the week
there's any any question or any cool
thing of the week that you think we
should share just let us know
yeah actually you know would be really
cool if somebody sent us an audio
recording of their question ooh that'd
be cool yes do that
yeah record your own audio asking a
question and email it to us that'd be
awesome or tweet it or whatever laughs
whatever we'll find a way awesome
that's a greater than mark thank you no
so yeah waiting for those and talk to
you mark and talk to you all next week
see you next week